.
Docteur Weiss, bonsoir.
- Oui, bonsoir, Patrice.
Ça va bien?
- Oui, ça va très bien, et vous?
- Oui, oui. L'été va bien. On a
quand même eu... On a eu un bon
été au Québec, et je pense qu'il
faut le souligner.
- Bon, bien, très bien.
Troisième dose, Docteur Weiss,
hier, le ministre de la santé
me disait : "On attend
des recommandations." Est-ce que
dans votre esprit, c'est
inévitable, on s'en va vers
une recommandation pour
une troisième dose pour tout
le monde, même ici?
- Bon, alors la troisième dose
est inévitable pour d'abord des
groupes ciblés. C'est-à-dire que
quand on regarde ce qui se passe
dans le monde, au niveau de la
science, on sait que les gens
de plus de 60 ans qui ont été
vaccinés il y a déjà plus
de 5-6 mois, qui ont eu leurs
deux dose, ont une certaine
perte de leur immunité.
Donc, il y a des pays qui ont
commencé à administrer
des troisième dose à des sous-
groupes particuliers et là,
on ne parle pas encore de toute
la population générale.
On ne parle pas de donner une
troisième dose à l'ensemble
des gens qui ont eu de dose.
On parle de donner une troisième
dose à des gens qui, on sait, à
cause de leur âge ou d'une
maladie sous-jacente, ont un
système immunitaire affaibli.
Et ces gens-là sont donc...
ont une certaine perte de leur
immunité de protection. Et c'est
dans ce contexte-là qu'on parle
de troisième dose, en sachant
que la vaccination maintenant
a fait ses preuves pour prévenir
la maladie sévère, pour prévenir
les hospitalisations, pour
prévenir des séjours en soins
intensifs et aussi pour prévenir
des décès. Disons, c'est là où
c'est surtout important parce
que c'est là où on veut
préserver notre système de santé
et ne pas revivre ce qu'on a
vécu au cours des vagues
précédentes.
- Mais pour le grand public,
vous ne voyez pas ça comme étant
une nécessité à court terme?
- Non, alors ce ne sera
probablement pas une nécessité
pour l'instant à court terme.
Ce qui risque d'arriver par
contre, et ce qu'il faut
souligner, c'est que sur
la planète, il y a à peu près
seulement 10 % de la population
mondiale qui a reçu ces deux
doses de vaccin. Donc, on l'a vu
au Québec. Au Québec,
on contrôle bien, je vous
dirais, la pandémie. On la
contrôle bien au Canada et même
aux États-Unis est bien sûr,
il y a des débats et des zones
un peu plus chaudes. Mais
globalement, on s'aperçoit que
là, on est revenu à une vie
beaucoup plus ouverte que ce
qu'on était auparavant et sans
la vaccination, nous n'aurions
jamais été capables de faire ça.
Donc, le fait qu'on ait pu
voyager, se promener au Québec,
aller au restaurant, recevoir
des amis, voir sa famille, etc.,
on a eu la coupe Stanley avec
des milliers de personnes dans
les rues de Montréal, et on n'a
pas eu d'impact majeur en termes
de société sur le nombre de cas
parce qu'on est arrivés à
immuniser un grand nombre de
personnes. Maintenant, comme à
l'échelle planétaire, il n'y a
pas forcément beaucoup de gens
qui sont immunisés, eh bien, ça
va faire perdurer la vie de la
COVID-19 dans le monde pour un
bout de temps. Donc, ça se peut
que dans deux ans peut-être,
dans un an et demi, qu'on
commence à parler de dose de
rappel à des gens plus jeunes,
plus en santé. Mais là, on pense
beaucoup, d'abord et avant tout,
aux personnes plus âgées
et aux personnes à risque.
- Deux questions avant de vous
laisser. Vaccination obligatoire
pour le personnel de la santé,
le Nouveau-Brunswick qui entre
dans le bal aujourd'hui,
l'Ontario hier, le Québec hier.
Est-ce que pour vous,
ça va de soi?
- Bien oui, ça va de soi.
C'est une question d'éthique.
Ça devient... Ça devient, vous
savez, une question d'éthique
normale et attendue. Je pense
qu'on ne parle pas de
vaccination universelle
d'obliger tout le monde se faire
vacciner, on parle de gens qui
sont des travailleurs de la
santé qui sont censés protégéer
les autres. Vous rappeler que la
première vague, malheureusement,
les gens qui sont décédés
au Québec dans les CHSLD,
on leur a amené le virus.
On leur a apporté le virus.
Et donc, c'est des gens qui ont
été infectés par des gens
qui sont entrés dans leur
environnement. Donc,
aujourd'hui... À cette époque-
là, on n'avait pas de vaccin.
Aujourd'hui, on a vaccin.
Ce serait non éthique, je vous
dirais, pour des gens qui
s'occupent de personnes à
risque, de personnes affaiblies,
de ne pas leur donner le maximum
de protection.
- Très bien. Docteur Weiss,
le... Des gens vaccinés,
doublement vaccinés, qui se sont
retrouvés quand même à
l'hôpital, on a vu, il y en a,
il y en a peu, mais il y en a,
qu'est-ce que ça vous dit sur
l'efficacité des deux doses?
Est-ce que ça vous émet un doute
ou au contraire, vous dites :
c'est normal qu'il y en ait
malgré tout?
- Bien, c'est tout à fait normal
qu'il y en ait malgré tout. Vous
avez vu que les vaccins,
dès le début, personne a dit que
c'était 100 % efficace. Dans les
études, on parlait d'efficacité
de 90 à 95 %. On sait par contre
que non seulement l'efficacité
est bonne, mais ça dépend quel
groupe d'âges vous regardait.
Si vous regardez les moins
de 60 ans, qui sont totalement
vaccinés, qui n'ont pas de
problèmes de santé, ces gens-là
vont quasiment pas à l'hôpital
et ces chiffres se répètent dans
tous les pays du monde. Si vous
regardez les plus de 60 ans qui
ont des problèmes de santé ou
qui ont des facteurs de risque,
même le fait d'être vacciné ne
leur donne pas une protection
absolue, mais réduit le risque
d'être hospitalisé, réduit le
risque d'être sévèrement malade,
d'être intubé ou même de
décéder, de facteurs qui varient
selon les études de 10 jusqu'à
25. Alors, c'est quand même
important. Malheureusement,
il y a aussi des gens qu'on
hospitalise, il faut savoir,
pour des raisons autres que la
COVID, mais qui testent positif
pour la COVID. Je vous donne un
exemple. Vous avez été vacciné
deux fois, vous faites un
infarctus, on vous hospitalise
pour votre infarctus, mais vous
avez été en contact avec un cas
de COVID et vous testez positif.
Vous êtes pas forcément malade
de la COVID hospitalisée, mais
vous êtes quand même hospitalisé
avec la COVID.
- Très bien. Docteur Weiss,
toujours un plaisir. Merci.
On se reparle. On va devoir se
reparler plusieurs fois.
Merci beaucoup.
- Ça me fait plaisir.
Bonne soirée.